the evan carmichael show i am your host
evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs i believe in you i want to
see you
reach the success that you're after i
know you're working hard i know you're
pouring everything you've got into your
business and it's time to get some
results
this is a really important show today
the content on this show could change
your business and your life forever
i just got back from a two-week trip in
europe had a great time was on board a
carnival cruise ship line
but i came back to be with you guys
we got a great show lined up today
on the agenda what i'm talking about
here it is number one don't rip off your
clients number two use social media
strategically number three don't be
average and number four eliminate the
words i can't from your vocabulary now
let's kick things off
don't rip off
your clients
if you want to have success if you want
to get people coming back to your
business telling their friends giving
you referrals spreading the word about
you
you don't want to rip off your clients
and i know it's tempting you got
somebody in the door you want to sell
them as much as you can because that's
money today that goes in your pocket but
you got to think bigger picture you got
to think about the long term you have to
think about the lifetime value
of the client
i was on carnival
and uh overall the cruise ship that's a
great deal you know i visited nine
cities in 10 days and to do that on my
own to think about travel airfare you
know transportation hotel costs all that
stuff would be a lot of money but it's
great value but once you get on board
the ship everything is a rip-off
it's all an upsell and it's a ridiculous
rip-off
just a quick example i want to get
online i want to get on into it
you want to get online on a cruise ship
it's going to cost you upwards of a
dollar per minute for slow as molasses
internet nobody signs up for that
thinking hey this is great value that
carnival's providing me with everybody
is upset they're pissed off because
they're getting ripped off and i saw
that sign
and to connect i said forget this
i'm voting with my wallet and i'm
choosing not to spend money with
carnival instead what i did
was i looked in each port that i landed
for starbucks
because i knew starbucks had wi-fi and
what did i do when i got to the
starbucks i spent money there
i bought a drink
i bought some food
this is a really important point of
differentiation don't be carnival
be starbucks
i chose purposely to avoid carnival
because i thought it was getting ripped
off
and decided to seek out
a starbucks i'm on vacation and i'm
looking to try to find a starbucks
taking time out of my vacation because i
know that they provide value it provided
what i was looking for
that's the power of that brand and you
need to do the same thing for your
business
every experience
with your business
should be amazing
every time somebody walks away from
interacting with you or anybody at your
company
it should leave them
feeling overwhelmingly happy you want
them not just satisfied but you want
them to be grateful
for having met you
grateful to spend money with you
and that comes from over delivering like
crazy and giving them way more value
than they ever expected
another example from carnival they have
what they call shore excursion
and this is where they take you on a
tour so we landed in florence you want
to go to florence they'll give you a bus
ride cost you 90 euros
over 100 bucks
for a bus ride to get into town
i did the same thing on my own for nine
bucks
are you kidding me
what kind of rip-off is this
and the thing is
what's what's the lasting impression
that i have with carnival
it's not a great one
am i going to say great things about
them
no am i going to tell my friends about
them no am i going to think twice about
going back on board their ship
absolutely
it's so important that you leave a
positive impression
all the time
with your clients and look for ways to
consistently over deliver like crazy
there's a number of ways to do it and it
comes from stop being average it's going
to be something we talk about later on
in the show but think about
every single offering that you're giving
your clients what are they paying you
for and what are they not paying you for
think about the service experience it
should be an experience
working with your company it needs to be
they need to walk away feeling better
about themselves better about their life
feeling like they have a solution to a
huge pain point because they met you
for me that wasn't carnival
to look at every single offering you
have
and look at how can you make it better
couple ways to do this number one you
know you should be an expert in your
field ideally you were one of your
potential customers before you know what
you're talking about and you look for
opportunities to make things
better
number two talk to your customers
and don't ask them
you know
you want to buy my product
just sit down have an informal chat and
learn about their daily life
learn about what makes them tick learn
about the biggest problem that they're
facing
right now in their business and their
life and see if there's a way that you
can make things easier for them it's
stepping up and going beyond what you're
currently offering to make something
amazing
stop ripping off
your clients i know again it's tempting
you want that money in the door it's
quick cash but you have to think about
the long-term relationship you have with
your customers
and really focusing on adding as much
value as you can
i want to get to the calls i've got
laura on the line laura where are you
from and how can i help hi evan
yes hi i'm from the new metro area and i
have a little bit different question if
you're trying to improve
let's say your presentation
in terms of being more articulate
and when you do a face-to-face you know
as you said it's very important to you
know sit with your client and
you know just informally go see where
he or she is coming from and what they
desire
how do you keep yourself because you
know you're so uh concentrate you're
concentrating so much on making a sale
and you know making the money keeping
your job how do you keep your nerves in
check
so that was the second part of my
question first
especially when you really need the deal
right
it correct correction like i feel can
make the difference between thinking or
making your business
that's true you're really liking the
payroll right right there's so many
expenses today so
unfortunately you know what if you don't
make that deal you might think the
company might go under and i know that's
stressful
here's what helped me
and if you want to make more sales try
not to think about the same
try to think about how you're helping
the customer
like these guys have
a big pain point
and you're here to help them you're here
to provide value and you should be able
to do that right you're an expert in
your field you should be able to do that
and tap into your passion for why you
started this business right you started
this company to make a difference if you
started just to make money then you're
in the wrong you're in the wrong
industry you got to change
but you started this business for a
reason i remember when i first started
helping uh some big companies
they came to me microsoft google tons of
huge companies came to me asking for
help and i was nervous like well
this is microsoft i'm doing with it's
not just some small entrepreneur here
and i was really nervous at the start
but what helped me get through it is
realizing that hey these guys are coming
for a reason i really know what i'm
talking about and i can help them and i
just focus the whole time
on helping them
instead of trying to sell myself
and when you do that
you have a lot stronger chance of being
able to close sale
right nobody wants to be sold to show
off your expertise make it credible and
and passionately believe
in what you're doing and it'll
dramatically increase the chances of you
being able to close the sale
so anytime i get nervous even sometimes
now you know i'm thinking about the
radio show what i'm going to talk about
i want to have an impact again instead
of getting nervous about it i just think
i'm going to be myself i'm going to tap
into my passion for helping
entrepreneurs i want to see you guys
succeed and that flows through
it flows through in my thinking it makes
me more confident and it makes me do a
much better job so apply that to your
business apply to your sales process you
have a lot more success
welcome back to the evan carmichael show
i want to see you have success in your
business and stop struggling and part of
that comes from having a smart social
media strategy
we'll get this wrong a lot of people
don't use their social media
strategically and have no idea what
they're doing now the first time i got
on twitter i thought it was a big waste
of time people talk about their cats
what they for lunch that were a huge
waste of time i'm spending my time
building my business why should i waste
it here
and then i found people were talking
about my company i did a search for my
name and saw people were mentioning me
and so i wasn't part of that
conversation and step one if you're just
getting started with twitter
is just monitor don't go on there and
start blasting out promotions and crap
that nobody's gonna pay attention to
step one is just follow
the conversation that's happening around
your company if you put up your twitter
account on your website
you will get people who will start to
write to you okay now you know don't
expect a huge flood at the start but you
will get people who are actively looking
to connect with you on twitter
before i went on my cruise
i tweeted the carnival i looked at their
account and said carnival listen i'm
coming on board in three days i'm
excited going on vacation looking
forward to your new boat
and you know what the response was
nothing
nothing i was shocked
it's like customers calling in to you
and you don't pick up the phone and
never call them back are you kidding me
the whole point of social media is you
to be social
and at least at the very least i was
expecting
a
hope you enjoyed the trip welcome aboard
have fun
instead carnival sends nothing
these guys don't get it
if it were me
i would at least say thank you but on
top of that i try to find a way to thank
the person
give them
a free dinner upgrade give them some
free internet time because we're ripping
them off anyway this stuff doesn't cost
them anything and instead of me ripping
on them for how bad they are at social
media i'd be praising them to be getting
free publicity from me going out there
saying how great carnival is
it's so important i know it's hard you
got a million things to do on your plate
but look at carnival okay they have 90
000 something followers
they have a team of people who manage
their account and they can't write back
to somebody
i have 200 000 followers almost i
respond to everybody who writes to me
and i do it personally it's not my team
doing it it's me
so step one before you start blasting
out a bunch of spam and stuff people
aren't going to care about
just follow the conversation around your
company and recognize the people who are
talking about you recognize your
champions because they feel good about
it they're going to keep promoting your
business for you
i want to get to the calls i have
danielle on the line danielle what's
going on where are you from and how can
i help
hi yeah i'm from chicago and i am trying
i've been working in restaurants for a
very long time all right there's been
serving managing all those things and
my husband is a chef and we want to open
our own restaurant um but so he knows
how to cook and i know how to manage the
floor but we don't really know anything
about
business-wise how to sort of begin a
venture like that so i'm kind of looking
for some some guidance on what to look
out for and like where those initial
steps can take protect ourselves sure
absolutely now why why do you want to do
this why don't you just want to be happy
with you know you know running the floor
and him being a chef what makes you want
to do your own business
you know we want to keep growing you get
to a certain point where you're like
okay we've done everything and we've
done it for other people and
we think we've got some pretty good
ideas in terms of what we want to do
he's talented i'm you know i'm great at
what i do and uh i think it would just
be
like an incredible kind of adventure i
know it won't be fun the whole way
through a lot of work but it'll be an
incredible adventure to see if we can to
make it on our own and especially in a
city where there's so much competition
in the culinary industry it's like how
do we stack up and uh we're you know
kind of we like the competition you know
now is your time
yes that's exciting okay um so the
restaurant business is is the highest
failure rate of any business in america
so it's definitely great to do your plan
before getting into it and a big reason
is the people who have started these
businesses one don't have anything
that's really different about them but
they're me too product and two
don't have the financial backing
understanding the financial systems that
you need to grow the business so let's
start with the first one what's
different about you guys what's what's
going to be special about this
restaurant that nobody in chicago has
ever seen
we do we've come from a couple of really
good restaurants i can't talk about it
right now because i don't want fun
who's listening
but
we come from a really supportive
background of very talented people so we
have
association going with going for us
we're not doing anything crazy in terms
of um it's really out there food like my
husband his family is originally from
cuba and there's not a huge cuban food
scheme but we're going to do latin food
and we're going to do it on
a higher end scale uh not inaccessible
but uh and we're also going to play into
whatever the you know the current trends
local seasonal it's really important to
a lot of people in the city who value
where their food comes from so our
restaurants in chicago aren't already
doing that there are restaurants in
chicago who are already doing that
i'm not afraid of that i don't i don't
need to be that one restaurant that does
that one thing and
and that's i understand that that's like
oh why not but at the same time we know
what we're good at we want to play to
our own strengths instead of
getting
wild and outside of our abilities
yeah and i mean you have to be
exceptional as something with your
business and it doesn't have to be plain
to that flavor of the month
but maybe it's about the service you
know like maybe you see a lot of things
that are wrong with service in the
restaurant business and what your
company stands for is radically
different than the current standard in
the restaurant business
absolutely and that is always important
to us and as a manager i definitely have
a great rapport with my servers but it's
also we
everywhere that i've worked it's always
been very important to make everyone
feel very welcome and also uh you know
when i was growing i grew up in a very
small town and i worked for a restaurant
that was
one of my first jobs and they put such a
huge emphasis on not doing too much
marketing um but doing a lot of word of
mouth and and just kind of letting this
everything speak for itself and
obviously that looks better in a small
town but i do want to sort of send
people away with this idea like oh you
have to come to this restaurant they use
like so welcoming so wonderful invest in
the customer experience
and not in the marketing
right people walk away and want to tell
their friends are you trying to raise
money for this but you have the funds
yourself
oh we have some funds that we've
accumulated over the years certainly not
enough to completely go solo but i do
have some mentors from my my years
coming up in in the industry uh who have
expressed interest so i want to go to
them with a solid business plan before i
say okay what about your facebook for
your checkbook
no absolutely and and i would really
encourage you to hone your pitch i mean
i saw thousands of deals come across my
desk when i was in the venture capital
business now you're definitely looking
more at the angel level
but
you got to have a clear message as to
what the opportunity is here and what's
going to be different about your
restaurant i think you have it it's just
not being articulated so if it's service
or if it's the cuban food or like what
makes most restaurants
terrible
and how can yours be amazing
right
it's going to be scary for a lot of
people to invest in in the business that
has the highest failure rate in america
i think you guys can do it
welcome back to devon carmichael show i
believe in you and entrepreneurs i want
to see you get some results from the
hard work that you're putting in and it
starts
by not being average
okay average being average being just
okay is a recipe for failure you're not
going to build a great company by being
average
i went on the carnival cruise ship and
on our last day
sitting around having our last meal
and it was thinking hey what was the
best food that we had on board this ship
you know we had 10 days on the boat what
was your favorite food
and nothing came to mind
you know nothing was terrible i didn't
get food poisoning i didn't i didn't you
know get sick
but nothing was great it was just okay
it was average
so then we expanded and thought okay
well fine the food wasn't great but what
about the ship you know what about the
ship was there anything gray what was
the memory last memory from the ship
and again nothing came up it was okay
you know we didn't have a mechanical
meltdown no major problems
but it was just okay
i've been on a dozen different cruises
before i'm a big fan of the industry and
a great way to travel but there's
nothing special about this boat
compared to the other boats that i was
on it was just okay
and the result of this
is i don't talk about it at least in a
positive way
but i'm not telling people you have got
to go on this boat because it's amazing
the food was amazing
the features were amazing
there's nothing great to talk about and
so you're forgettable
we expanded the search and started
thinking about
the entire trip all the businesses that
we saw all the different entrepreneurs
that we visited
you know ten ten days nine different
cities
every day i got off went to visit
different entrepreneurs different shops
went to talk to them learned about their
businesses
and for the most part almost everybody
was the same thing
average
just okay
no lasting memories
the one guy who had an impact on me
was the shop owner in florence
and this guy had a leather good store he
was selling jackets and purses and
wallets anything you wanted to do with
leather
and when it came to the store he greeted
me
and my town's a little rusty but he
worked with me and he told me about the
city he told me about the history told
me about the bike race that was
happening that day the asking where i
was from
and
i'm sad that i didn't really like
anything in his store they didn't buy
anything but he'd left a lasting memory
with me as i was walking out of the
store he said kisses to you
i hope you have a great vacation
and so here was a guy
who's left a mark
and he's somebody who will talk about
and refer people to
and again i wish that i liked some of
the stuff in his store
but of all the businesses that i met of
all the entrepreneurs that i came across
he was the only one who really stood out
now going around europe
this is happening everywhere
and this presents
a humongous challenge for you
but also a massive opportunity
it's a problem
because you're probably average
the things you do are average the
business is just average it's okay
there's nothing great about it it's not
bad
you know you're not
angering your customers hopefully
but it's not great
there's nothing memorable there's no
reason for people to talk about you
welcome to the world of you know the
eighty percent this is everybody
and it's the reason why most businesses
fail eighty percent of businesses will
fail
it's a huge number
it doesn't have to be that way but if
you just keep doing the same thing that
everybody else is doing in your industry
those guys are going to fail too
you have to find a way to stand out and
be different
this is where the opportunity comes in
there's a huge opportunity because your
competition is average too
they're not doing anything memorable
they're not doing anything to stand out
there may be slightly better than you
and so customers go to them just because
there's no other great option
you need to give people a reason to talk
about you
to be great
do something that really stands out and
puts you on the map when we're talking
to the last caller
about the restaurant in chicago
there's tons of restaurants in chicago
and it sounds like she has you know
great experience great background years
in the business and her fiance the chef
it's a killer combination
but again there's nothing great in her
pitch at least i believe there's
something great in each of us
but you got to let that come out
if you don't
then you make it hard for people to talk
about you
you make it hard for your customers to
tell their friends about you
because you're just like carnival
you're okay
it was okay it was average nothing
special
but your homework today is to start
thinking about how you can really make
your business stand out how you can
really add a ton of value to your
customers and give them something worth
talking about
a guy recently wrote into me
and he has uh he wants to start a flower
shop
and again flower shop listen that's the
competitive business it's hard to start
a flower shop the margins aren't great
you gotta love the flower business to do
well in it
and he's got tons of competition and you
know welcome to the world of business we
all have tons of competition
there's not a lot of industries that
have no competition
so you're fighting
and so i asked them listen what is
different about your business why do you
want to start this thing
and he said
because flowers
make him come
when he's around flowers he calms down
he has a hectic life he carries a lot of
stress with him and being around all
these flowers makes him have that
feeling of calm
and i said this is fantastic this is
what you need to build your whole
business around
because there's tons of people who feel
the same way
they want to feel calm they have
stressed out life
the whole business
should be about being calm and you
should bring in the flowers
that feel that make you feel calm you
should have a logo a company name
signage that makes you feel calm the
whole display
of your store the music that you play
the staff that you hire everything
should be about being calm and the
people who will come to you are the ones
who want to become
those are your ideal clients because
they're the people who can relate to
what your message is they believe in the
same thing that you do
you have to pour more of yourself
into your business think about what you
stand for think about what you believe
in that's the unique differentiator this
is how you stand out this is how you go
beyond being average beyond being just
okay and get people to talk about you
i have a mechanic
who fixes my vespa
his name is george and george is an
amazing guy he believes in family he
treats everybody like they're part of
his family
that should be part of his brand
that's what makes him stand out i pass
people on to his business i i
recommended my father
to go see him
because george treats everybody like
family
the problem is in his business
his staff doesn't treat you like family
they're they're good
they're just average they're okay
this store is set up like any other
store
this website is like any other website
there's nothing unique about the entire
business except george
and if george poured more of himself
into his business and encapsulated that
family concept that he believed in and
treated everybody like family
and had his staff treat everybody like
family
you would attract customers who wanted
to be that way you want to be treated
like that when you walk into george's
shop he'll give you an espresso they'll
ask you how you're doing he'll chat with
you he'll talk to you about your bike
he'll teach you he treats you basically
like you're his cousin
and that's why i recommend the people on
to him
your business has to have that
differentiator that people would want to
recommend their parents to you
just like i did
and the answer doesn't have to be
that difficult the answer already lies
within you it's something that you
believe passionately in that you can
apply
to your business
if i look at george
and his family belief
whatever business george starts
if it's mechanic or something else he's
always going to believe in family he's
always going to treat his customers like
family whether he sold shoes whether he
showed bikes whether he sold cars
anything
you said at a website company he would
treat people like family that's his core
belief
you have to find yours and start
applying it
to your business
think about
a word or a concept
that cuts to your core
so it's not just about your business
it's not what your business stands for
it's what you stand for
and when you understand what that is
it'll be so much easier to bring on a
team
to raise money to get ideal clients
coming into you
to get media attention because you're
giving people a message that is easy to
spread
you're giving them something that's
unique that's different that means
something and they'll get people excited
it's so important
it's so important because most
businesses don't do that and most
businesses shut down and fail because of
it
so that's your homework for tonight
think about the one thing that you stand
for and how you can apply to business to
help you stand out and not be average
anymore welcome back to the evan
carmichael show i want to see you have
massive discuss with your business and
one way to do it is to remove the words
i can't from your vocabulary when you
say i can't you close down worlds of
opportunities that can help take you to
the next level
when i was on the carnival cruise ship
i got on board i went on the elevator i
started going down and the dj for the
boat popped on the same elevator as me
and i was excited now i love latin music
i'm an investor in a salsa dancing
company here in toronto and spend maybe
20 hours a week dancing djing and i
wanted to hear some music
so i talked to the guy and said hey do
you have any kizomba music gizmo was a
new dance that we started teaching i
wanted to practice
and the first thing he said was i can't
and right there i thought this guy
doesn't get it
how hard would it have been to say
let me go back to my cabin i'm going to
spend some time i'll go online
find a song and play it for you tonight
it would have taken five minutes out of
his day to make a customer happy and he
didn't do it better yet
you should have said hey you know what i
don't usually play kizomba music but
what's your favorite song
and i'll play it for you tonight one
track that would have made my day it
would have given me something to talk
about i would have gone to see him
every night
because he believed in service
and it's not so much him that i blame
it's carnival
right they are not hiring and training
people
to provide great service to their
customers
that's what it's all about
you have to look at ways to think
outside the box and provide great
solutions for your customers sometimes
that may even mean leading them onto a
competitor
because you can't help them
but instead of ripping them off and
selling them a solution they don't need
you're really helping them and the next
time they have a problem they're going
to come back to you
don't say i can't think about it think
about some solution that you can help
them with
to make an impact because that's going
to make all the difference in the world
for them whether they buy for you or not
and whether to refer business onto you
or not i want to get to the calls i have
tatiana on the line tatiana where are
you from and how can i help
hi evan thank you so much for taking my
call um so i'm originally from brazil
but i've been living in the states for
about
um 12 years
um i have a settlement that is coming to
me pretty soon
and um
by
my entire the entire time that i've been
here in the states have been
in the restaurant business
and i
was trying to invest in one because i
know so many people in the industry okay
um
and
i don't but i know that it's a very iffy
business but i don't have a whole lot of
money to open a whole new restaurant and
i don't want the responsibility to be
day in and day out i just want to invest
that money okay you as a business person
you know what's the best way to invest
something that you have that it's not
going to come all the time it's one big
investment that i want
so i i have a little bit of security so
either that or because i have a lot of
friends
or
you know in a in a portfolio or like
just put it away what's your what's your
advice okay this is important
because this is your nest egg right
i don't want you to lose your life
savings on the wrong investment
that's what i'm afraid of right now the
restaurant business is as we talked with
our last caller the highest failure rate
of any company and i know that yeah
right now that's not meant to scare you
it's just to say hey these are the facts
if you're investing
i mean i always encourage people as much
as possible to invest in themselves
so
i don't know if you ever have plans to
start your own business if it's
restaurant related or not
but if you're going to give money to
somebody else if you're going to become
a partner in the business it's got to be
something that you really believe in
like fundamentally to your core and you
get along really well with the people in
that business
right it's like getting married you have
to make sure you really love the person
and what they stand for and what's going
to happen with the company because if
you guys start to fight it's gonna get
ugly and that's your whole life saving
i would really you know as much as i
like entrepreneurship and opportunity
i'm scared for you to put that money
into another business and let somebody
else run
with your life savings
i would really honestly look at how can
i invest that money into something safer
until you're ready to do something on
your own
and that's safer route what would that
be um would you say bond stock or
put it away in a portfolio for a couple
of
years and then just make some money out
of that or really why aren't you those
are my choices
yeah i mean you wanted something that
you feel is safe for you it depends on
what your risk tolerance is but for me i
put my extra money into stocks
and i'm not a gamble in the stock market
i put a lot of money
but the risk money i put into myself
because i feel like i can deliver better
results than any other investment that
i've been into
right i understand
but the the money on top of that you're
talking about my you know retirement
savings funds
that's that's in a mix of of different
stocks
if you're going to be retiring soon you
want to have something a little safer
like you can get into some bonds and if
you talk to an investment professional
they can help guide your decision and
how much risk tolerance you have
okay investing in another company
is
is a huge risk
okay so definitely make that a part of
your
a part of your overall budget but i
would still
if it were me
i would look at doing something for
myself
looking at a way that i might be able to
start a business at some point you know
maybe you're not ready yet maybe it's
related to restaurants maybe it's
related to something totally different
using that money
as your fallback
you know using that money is your your
retirement plan because i still want to
make sure when you
when you get to that age you have
something there
and
it's often easy for us to get greedy
and see these opportunities coming to us
and people pitching us and so we want to
jump on board a quick quick money-making
opportunity they rarely work out
okay thank you so much evan for your
um advice i will definitely look into it
no problem believe thank you
thank you
if you guys so if everybody else is
facing the same thing if you are looking
at putting money into an operation make
sure that you can bring something more
than just
you've got to be able to bring expertise
contact experience and i don't want you
to lose your life savings i hate
spending money until i'm making money
so invest in yourself first
and if you're going to start your
business the great way to do it but make
sure you have that nest egg that you're
growing there's something there for your
retirement
i've had a great show with you guys i
hope you've enjoyed i'm going to be back
in two weeks i want to thank the
producers i had a great time here
fernanda and steve you guys are awesome
lining everything up for me just as a
summary guys remember we're not ripping
off our clients
we're using social media strategically
we are not being average
and you're limiting the words don't i
can't from your vocabulary see you guys
in two weeks have a great time building
your business